when you're an adult all your learning
isn't always going to be inside of a
building we don't really decide what
happens every day unless there's a plan
to outing or event that we're going to
attend most days we just kind of finish
up where we have maybe left off the day
before on a project or sometimes we're
too spontaneous anita rios sherman has
six children under the age of 18 five of
them are on the autism spectrum today
the four youngest children will spend
the morning at the local Natural History
Museum where they'll explore redraw and
play with each other it's an educational
philosophy known as unschooling they
decided to try unschooling when the
local public schools failed to meet the
needs of her oldest son she found that
he benefited from a totally unstructured
approach to learning and then tried the
same method with her other children
there are many things about the
unschooling philosophy that work really
well with children that are on the
autism spectrum a lot of it has to do
with allowing them to explore their
passions for them not to have to earn
that time to explore those things
because passions can turn into real life
careers school is a place where children
learn to be stupid the process that
makes them stupid at least stupid in
school is other people trying to control
their learning that's John Holt who's
the intellectual Godfather of the modern
home schooling movement in a sense he's
the moral leader of a movement in this
country on the part of a significant
number of American families to take
their kids out of school and teach them
at home there's a common perception that
home schoolers are social conservatives
who want to shield their children from
the modern world it's good for the child
to get out of the home get away from mom
and dad and talk to other people because
when they become adults they've got that
problem but Holt had a different view of
the dangers of school in his 10 books
Holt argued that children were capable
of self-directed learning possessing a
natural curiosity that's quashed by
modern schools they treat them like an
empty receptacles into which they are
going to pour
whatever learning they think they ought
to have and unschooling when you say it
today people have video so you don't
believe in schools it's tricky because
what John means by unschooling is
learning that doesn't have to take place
at home and that doesn't look like
school you know because we're learning
all the time
pat fir anga is the publisher of a
magazine turned website that promotes
Holtz philosophy and the unschooling
movement schools believe and most
teachers believe children will not learn
unless they are taught and in order to
be taught the teacher must have X number
of years of training and they can only
teach the subjects that they've been
trained in however children and most
adults when they're not in school and
most kids when they're not in school
learn holistically they learn from all
their senses and they learn from their
experiences the relationships and to
just bottle it up and say that now we're
gonna learn math is is artificial we
were the only game in town in the 1980s
and 90s unschooling was pretty much a
small niche now there you go online
there's anything from pagan unschoolers
to radical unschoolers and that to me is
a great sign because there's a lot more
of us but while unschooling is closely
tied to homeschooling the two are not
synonymous Ferengi maintains a list of
alternative schools that embrace some
form of self-directed learning I
absolutely consider unschooling a
spectrum and that's and again if you
read John's books freedom and beyond and
instead of education in particular he
talks about other places and you know
where children and adults can be to
learn besides school
one such example is the Houston Sudbury
school based on the Sudbury Valley
School model pioneered in Massachusetts
in 1968 students here who range in age
from 6 to 17 play and learn with each
other attend optional lessons in various
subjects and each have an equal vote on
how the school is run and money
allocated I encountered some limitations
to that primarily how much I as a parent
had to be involved in decision making so
I became interested in this idea of was
there a school that carried the same
philosophy as unschooling but gave kids
some autonomy from their parents and I
had heard about Sudbury so the founders
really came from the unschooling
community here in Houston
so in this environment the kids really
can use the resources here the space the
community the money and really create
the life that they want get on to like
sit in one space like you just get to go
wherever I mean there's rules but you
can just do whatever you want so for a
long time in school I had a lot of
problems with learning and I was in
special a lot of special ed classes the
unstructured environment has been
probably one of the best things to
happen to me in my life to not be going
to school all day and just being not
happy with life you're not being in a
classroom for days with your mental
health slowly deteriorating because of
endless classwork you're going to be
interacting with people and developing
more social skills and responsibilities
because everybody is held accountable
for what they do here so in Sudbury you
get a chance to really explore what you
want to do instead of just being forced
into stuff that
really doesn't interest you there is
just so much freedom in public school
you kind of just like set out a desk and
listen to your teacher and that's I
definitely learned what public school
wanted me to learn I listened in class I
was like paid attention I got good
grades but here you I learned about what
I want to learn about they even have a
daily Judicial Conference where they
deal with rule breakers during today's
conference they sent a six-year-old out
to investigate who crumpled up a
printout but came up empty-handed and
decided to drop the matter while in the
public school you have to go to a
teacher or talk about something I
haven't and typically they don't do a
good job of sorting out a lot of those
things and JC is something happens even
something small you write that up and it
gets talked about it's a very orderly
thing there's no arguments it's mostly
about figuring out what happened and
what can be done better enrolling in a
school like Sudbury can be really scary
they're not getting what they would get
in a traditional education I was really
afraid in thinking about this completely
unstructured living for kids but in my
experience these kids actually end up
quite a bit more prepared in some ways
than someone who's had a traditional
education because they're actually
participating in a lot more of the
real-life activities that people do
making a huge decision for a group with
the members of a group when the group
doesn't always agree while some parents
might cringe to see their kids spending
much of the day just hanging out playing
video games or looking at their phones
believers in the Sudbury approach
maintained that the kids will learn what
they need when they need to do it I
consider it a huge disadvantage to keep
kids from these devices in this
technology which is what they need to be
learning how to navigate in our culture
many of the kids who are interested in
gay
and computers are the kids who will grow
up to be in those fields making the next
big evolution in technology there is
plenty of time to gain everything that
you can gain at public school right here
at Sudbury and a lot of students do and
they actually learn it as opposed to
pretending to learn it for a test if the
whole high school happens in six months
at a Sudbury school I still believe they
learn it better than they would over
years and years of being forced to
memorize it like most Sudbury schools
this one is private with a seven
thousand dollar annual tuition fee that
they often modify to accommodate
lower-income parents we would love for
this school to be available to families
regardless of their income but I would
not want to enter into any kind of
situation where we are accountable to
the state
while the school choice movement has
brought explosive growth in the number
of charter schools nationwide
unschoolers haven't felt much affect
home schoolers haven't been able to take
advantage of school choice because
there's no funding available for
homeschooling that's not considered a
choice that's changed somewhat with
educational savings accounts which allow
home schoolers in some states to set
aside a portion of their tax dollars for
education but fer anga is skeptical of
government involvement when the school
superintendent in the district where he
lives
earmarked funds for home schoolers like
him in the 90s it eventually rescinded
the money on the grounds that their
activities were non educational 99% of
the stuff we did in this house I'd say
with board games behind me and projects
there's a lot of different things that
are educational if you believe that
you're learning all the time and we are
learning all the time the world is your
oyster but instead it's like oh no
that's not educational well who
determines that instead for anga
continues to advocate for unschooling as
a social movement focused on the rights
and personal freedoms of children to
find their own way right now the best
thing you could do if you can't
homeschool your child is ignore as much
of school as possible and pay attention
to what your child really wants to do
and work with that
you